votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com c'est dégueulasse
[Musique]
béret noir
très vite
[Musique]
m
ce qui dépasse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai été saisi à cette année
[Musique]
amis
j'ai tout noir
mais
à trop garder la serbie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des crocos volet veut pas de faire
s'accroche au pouvoir
on n'est que lundi vous ai déjà pensé et
tout cela pour arriver le sort de ce
corps série buzz l'éclair génial
quignard même pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais si on gagne et un mi temps est un
mythomane
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hello
[Rires]
bonjour je suis handicapé par mr procès
déguisement c'est qu'on était des
déguisements je suis né au nahd dicaprio
moi je connaissais tu avais ma nouvelle
voiture à la paix patine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du marché quand je marche avec la
période voilà quand je marche au ralenti
maurice à redire quand je marche si
c'est le nombre d'accords richard pas
décharger pour manitou matin pour canale
donc les défis du mode on a déclaré
chardy en bois du gardien sur jean
frappât attend
[Musique]